is there ways
in which mathematics can lead us astray
when we use it as a tool to understand
the physical world
yes i would say that mathematics can
lead us astray as much as
all physical ideas can lead us to
strength so
it is if you get stuck in some something
then you can easily fool yourself that
just like
uh the thought process we have to free
ourselves of that
sometimes math does that rule like say
oh this is such a beautiful math
i definitely want to use it somewhere
and so you just get carried away and you
just get maybe carried too far away so
that is certainly true but i wouldn't
say
it's more dangerous than all physical
ideas to me
new math ideas is as much potential to
lead us astray as all physical ideas
which could be
long-held principles of physics so i'm
just saying that we should keep an open
mind about the role the math plays not
to be antagonistic towards it
and not to over overwhelming it we
should just be open to possibilities
you